[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue et merci de
votre agent chantal et alice présente le
journal les autres s'occupent de la
régie le sont les caméras le lancement
des reportages une manière de découvrir
les coulisses de la télévision
ça des fois on est peut-être un petit
peu largué jeudi
mais bon on s'en sort quand même à peu
près fait quoi l'avenir le dira un jour
je sais pas d'abord personne ne sait ce
que je vais vous connaissez cette parole
victor hugo sur la peau les os cela veut
dire à personne la ville et adieu sir
paul dont 113
avenue victor hugo pour les allées ce
projet a été lancé suite à une étude en
interne qui révélait que les résidents
s'ennuyait
c'était l'opportunité de leur montrer
que effectivement il était acteur ici de
leur vie créer un journal télévisé comme
activité c'est aussi une manière de
montrer aux familles le quotidien de
leurs proches derrière ces murs alors
justement il ya beaucoup de jeunes sur
le plateau monsieur bernard qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait donner comme conseille à
tous ces jeunes un concept tout simple
mais croire en la vie c'est beau ce qui
donnerait là mais c'est ce qui est beau
ce qu'ils veulent
je vous présente un candidat que vous à
débattre que c'est l'ordre que j'ai
reçus en coulisses à 7 des consignes
très très ferme ce sont des ordres c'est
nonce pas désordre c'est si vous ne
voulez pas qu'on fasse du mal il faut
que vous battiez caroline c'est tout
jusque là je trouvais qu'on était plutôt
bien traités mais du coup la
bienveillance n'a plus sa place et s'il
ya un moment il faut arrêter le côté à
vii formidable sain je vous aime pas et
il faut passer à
la vraie vie et la vraie vie n'est pas
toujours tendre monsieur
et perds tu te plantes non calcaire et
je te plains cependant nous
moi ce qui me fait peur c'est la
délinquance et l'absence de réponse
pénale en face de cette délinquance bah
c'est ça mon
souci c'est la peur aussi
d'une intrusion d'une autre culture j'ai
des biens d'une intrusion et d'une
suprématie d'une autre culture je crois
que pour aimer les autres et moi je suis
xénon fils moi j'adore les étrangers
mais je considère qu'il faut s'aimer soi
même zemmour ou marine le pen vous
mettez le bulletin ou bas pour l'instant
je mettrais chez marine d'accord parce
que je la trouve je trouve qu'elle il ya
une base populaire est un acteur faut
mieux dire que tu votes à gauche mais
c'est aussi con que d'aller dire que tu
votes pour le pen parce que tu sais que
ta carrière est finie quoi ah mais déjà
faut dire que c'est souvent le contraire
c'est quand la carrière est finie on dit
qu'on vote
les cheveux dans la salle et moi ma
femme est sénégalaise
donc j'ai là dessus j'ai pas de leçon de
la recevoir
ah oui quand il dit ça ça bloque à bas
la wii c'est voilà la famille
sénégalaise là le contrecoup donc j'ai
pas compris pourquoi j'ai allumé un
contre-feu
ça faisait longtemps la nuit noire où je
mange du couscous fins et tout ça c'est
la même chose il faut c'est fini tu
t'appelles ces années 80 ça marche le
plus je n'aime pas le couscous part je
veux dire on peut très bien non mais
finalement il ya lieu sur le terrain
blanc par exemple sa femme est content
parce qu'il ya quelques semaines disait
que sa femme lui coûté un peu cher si
haut il est sympa aussi
moi j'aime bien la dentelle c'est
séduisant mais si je réussis sur rentrer
comme ça rien t'as pas 5000 euros de
niveau pour pour rien qu'il faut
abbas il le dit j'accepte de mettre en
maillot de bain sur le plateau c'est à
vous parce que mais parce que j'ai un
maillot de bain aspect si j'ai bien fait
de venir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rassurer vous rassurer
lescure
[Musique]
simplement
[Rires]
je trouves pas qu'elle soit sexy ou
provocants j'aime bien et au moins on en
avant les gi barras à 1000
depuis je n'ai pas lâché l'affairé que
5000 euros et qui zappe et au cours d'
alvin we have ou trois choses que tu
cries pendant le sexe non un an
attention pas pris
7 rebonds à table
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que des gens qui sont en train
de faire l'amour nous regardons
robert ça ferait plaisir ayem plus
trollage mais
jamais nous on va pas faire l'amour ici
à robert c'est les gens à la télé
faites-leur un bisou robert à tous les
gens qui font l'amour
une chatte en chaleur par exemple
brignoles et la salle et je vous ai dit
que c'était presque toute l'année ça
revient très fréquemment en fait donc
elle miaule beaucoup un miaulement hyper
ro donc ça c'est pas sympa pour nous
c'est sympa oui c'était donc la chatte
en chaleur j'essaye mais j'ai
adopté même encore plus fort
on peut imaginer en cours
[Rires]
j'ai vécu à la ferme quand vous étiez
[Applaudissements]
il y en a beaucoup dans le film
justement d'humanité n'a pas que dans
l'adresse de cet hymne parisienne et là
aussi il y en a eu s'il y en a eu aussi
beaucoup dans la réalité ce que vous
montrez de la generali la générosité de
la part des soignants c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous êtes lancé dans un
tour de france
j'ai des médicaments dans ma loge ça
s'appelle du pronom saxe
le prononce axe mais j'ai chaud depuis
je me suis mis à y voir c'est l'enfer
le comité miss france à attaqué aux
prud'hommes par l'association osez le
féminisme en cause les critères de
recrutement jugé discriminatoire les
candidates devant mesurer au moins 1
mètre soixante dix être célibataire et
sans enfant un concours qui violerait le
droit du travail selon l'association
l'association qui s'appuie sur le
témoignage de plusieurs femmes qui
disent avoir dû renoncer à se présenter
en raison de ces critères cesti lui
voilà je peux m'inscrire pour le casting
du mannequinat ça marche ou pas
alors on adel tombe bien mal voyants
mélanie
nouvel attelage et dans leur ont dit pas
netflix ont dit n'être flash de balle de
match hier dès 10 h avec ce secret c'est
un danseur 6 2 ans netflix bon alors
pour les ch'tis là c'est impossible là
non je la prononciation scénique à
l'appui le début de l'émission elle est
coupable il n'y a eu aucune erreur